i want to explain
what is happening
why it is happening
and what
we propose
to do about it
i trust the british people
and i know they understand no government
can solve every problem
particularly the complex and global
challenge of inflation
but this government
will never stop trying to help people
to fix problems to fix problems where we
can
to do what is right as we did throughout
the pandemic
[Applause]
we need to make sure
that for those whom the struggle is too
hard
and for whom the risks are too great
they
are supported
this government will not sit idly by
whilst there is a risk that some in our
country might be set so far back
they might never recover
this is simply unacceptable
and we will never allow that to
happen and i want to reassure everybody
we will get through this
we have the tools and the determination
we need to combat and reduce inflation
we will make sure the most vulnerable
and least well-off get the support they
need at this time of difficulty
and
we will turn this moment of difficulty
into a springboard for economic renewal
and growth with more jobs higher skills
greater investment
our plan for a stronger economy
madam deputy speaker before i turn to
the details of our plan let me put into
context for the house the challenge we
face
this country is now experiencing the
highest rate of inflation we have seen
for 40 years
the bank of england expect inflation to
average
around 9
this year our exposure to global shocks
continues to explain
most of the inflation above the two
percent target
supply chain disruption as the world
reopened from covid combined with
russia's invasion of ukraine and
potentially exacerbated by recent
lockdowns in china
are all contributing to significant
price increases for goods and energy
however
over the course of the year
the situation has evolved and has become
more serious
there are areas of particular concern
even excluding energy and food
core inflation has become broader based
and elevated
of the basket of goods and services we
use to measure inflation a record
proportion are seeing above average
price increases
also
we are acutely exposed
to the european energy price shock
and like the us we also have a tight
labor market
make no mistake the lowest unemployment
in almost 50 years just months after
averting a jobs crisis during the
pandemic is good news
but combined with the shock to european
energy prices it does contribute to the
uk's relatively high rate of inflation
and lastly as the bank have noted
longer longer-term inflation
expectations have risen above their
historical averages by more than they
are in the us and europe
we cannot
and must not allow short-term
inflationary pressures to lead people to
expect that high inflation will continue
over the long term
because madam deputy speaker
we can get inflation under control
it is not some abstract force outside
our grasp it may take time
but we have the tools we need and the
resolve it will take to reduce inflation
madam deputy speaker we have three
specific tools available to combat and
reduce inflation
and we are using them all
independent monetary policy
fiscal responsibility
and supply-side activism
first our primary tool is a strong
independent monetary policy
since control of monetary policy was
taken out of the hands of politicians 25
years ago
inflation has averaged precisely 2
percent
it is right that the bank of england are
independent and i know the governor and
his team
will take decisive action to get
inflation back on target and ensure
inflation expectations remain firmly
anchored
second we need responsible fiscal policy
that means providing fiscal support
where required
but not making the situation
unnecessarily worse causing inflation
interest and mortgage rates to go up
further than they otherwise would
excessively adding fiscal stimulus into
a supply-constrained economy especially
one in which households and businesses
have built up over 300 billion pounds of
excess savings
risks being counterproductive and
increasing inflationary pressures
in other words fiscal support should be
timely
temporary and targeted
timely because we need to help people
when the shock is at its worst
targeted because unconstrained stimulus
will make the problem worse and
temporary
because if we do not meet our fiscal
rules and ensure the public finances are
resilient in the longer run
we create even greater risks on
inflation interest rates and the trend
rate of economic growth
and third we are taking an activist
approach to supply side reforms
this will increase our productive
capacity
ease inflationary pressures and raise
our long-term growth potential
the prime minister's energy security
strategy will over time reduce bills by
increasing energy supply and improving
energy efficiency
the work and pension secretary is moving
half a million job seekers off welfare
and into work
and doing more to support older people
back into the jobs market the home
secretary is making our visa regime for
high-skilled migrants one of the most
competitive in the world
and in the autumn we will bring forward
tax cuts and reforms to encourage
businesses to invest more train more and
innovate more the path to higher growth
so independent monetary policy fiscal
responsibility supply side reform
the country should have confidence that
using these three tools we will combat
inflation and that households are being
hit hard right now
so today madam deputy speaker
we will provide significant support to
the british people
but as i have said
a critical part of how we are dealing
with inflation is responsible fiscal
policy
what this means in practical terms is
that as we support people more
we need to think about the fairest way
to fund as much of that cost as possible
the oil and gas sector is making
extraordinary profits
not
not as the results
[Applause]
not as the result of recent changes to
risk taking or innovation or efficiency
but as the result of surging global
commodity prices driven in part by
russia's war
and for that reason i am sympathetic to
the argument to tax those profits fairly
[Applause]
but as ever
but
a bit of gentle banter is fine but when
it gets to the stage that nobody can
hear what the chancellor is saying it's
counterproductive
quieter banter please chancellor the
ex-jacket
but
as ever
there is a sensible middle ground
we should not be ideological about this
we should be pragmatic
it is possible to both tax extraordinary
profits fairly
and incentivize investment
and so like previous governments
including conservative ones we will
introduce a temporary targeted energy
profits levy but
we have built into the new levy
but
we have built into the new levy
but we have built into the new levy
a new investment allowance similar to
the super deduction
that means
that means companies will have a new and
significant incentive to reinvest their
profits
the new levy will be charged on profits
of oil and gas companies at a rate of 25
it will be temporary and when oil and
gas prices return to historically more
normal levels the levy will be phased
out with a sunset clause written into
the legislation
and crucially and crucially
with our new investment allowance
we are nearly doubling the overall
investment relief for oil and gas
companies
that means for every pound a company
invests
they'll get back 90 percent in tax
relief
so the more a company invests the less
tax they will pay
[Music]
and we understand also
that certain parts of the electricity
generation sector
are also making extraordinary profits
the reason for this is the way our
market works the price electricity
generators are paid that are paid as
linked not to the cost they incur in
providing that electricity but rather to
the price of natural gas which is
extraordinarily high right now
other countries like france italy spain
and greece have already taken measures
to correct this
as set out in the energy security
strategy we are consulting with the
power generation sector and investors to
drive forward energy market reforms and
ensure the price paid for electricity is
more reflective of the cost of
production
but those reforms will take time to
implement so in the meantime we are
urgently evaluating the scale of these
extraordinary profits and the
appropriate steps to take
so madam deputy speaker our energy
profits levy will encourage investment
not deter it
it raises around five billion pounds of
revenue over the next year so that we
can help families with a cost of living
and it avoids having to increase our
debt burden further because there is
nothing noble in burdening future
generations with ever more debt today
because politicians of the day were too
weak to make the tough decisions
madam deputy speaker
i know the whole house will agree
we have a responsibility
to help those who through no fault of
their own
are paying the highest price for the
inflation we face
to help with the cost of living
we are going to provide significant
targeted support to millions of the most
vulnerable people in our society
those on the lowest incomes
pensioners and disabled people
first people on the lowest incomes over
8 million households already have
incomes low enough for the state to be
supporting their cost of living through
the welfare system
they could be temporarily unemployed and
looking for work
unable to work because of long-term
sickness or disability or on low pay and
using benefits to top up their wages
right now
they face incredibly difficult choices
so i can announce today
we will send directly to around 8
million of the lowest income households
a one-off cost of living payment of
650 pounds
[Applause]
support worth over 5 billion pounds to
give vulnerable people certainty that we
are standing by them at this challenging
time
[Music]
dwp will make the payment in two lump
sums the first from july the second in
autumn with payments from hmrc for those
on tax credits following shortly after
there is no need for people to fill out
complicated forms or bureaucracy we will
send the payment straight to their bank
accounts
our policy will benefit over 8 million
households in receipt of means-tested
benefits from july
operating in that time frame
could only be done for those on
universal credit
and our policy
will provide a larger average payment
this year of 650 pounds whereas
upgrading the same benefits by 9
would be worth only on average
530 pounds
there are two further groups who will
need extra targeted support many
pensioners are disproportionately
impacted by higher energy costs
they can't always increase their incomes
through work and because they spend more
time at home and are more vulnerable
they often need to keep the heating on
for longer
and we estimate many people who are
eligible for pension credit are not
currently claiming it which means there
will be many vulnerable pensioners not
receiving means-tested benefits
so i can announce today that from the
autumn we will send over eight million
pensioner households who receive the
winter fuel payment an extra one-off
pensioner cost of living payment of 300
pounds
disabled people also face extra costs in
their day-to-day lives
like having energy-intensive equipment
around the home or workplace
so to help the six million people who
receive non-means-tested disability
benefits we will send them from
september an extra one-off disability
cost of living payment worth 150 pounds
many disabled people will also receive
the payment of 650 pounds i have already
announced taking their total cost of
living payments to 800 pounds
and i can reassure the house that next
year
subject to the secretary of state's
review
benefits will be upgraded by this
september's cpi which on current
forecasts is likely to be
significantly higher than the forecast
inflation rate for next year
similarly the triple lock will apply for
the state pension
[Music]
of course we recognize the risk that
with any policy there may be small
numbers of people who will fall between
the cracks for example it is not
possible right now for dwp or hmrc to
identify people on housing benefit who
are not also claiming other benefits
so to support them and others we will
extend the household support fund
delivered by local authorities
by half a billion pounds from october
this
is a significant set of interventions to
support the most vulnerable in our
country
we will legislate to deliver this
support on the same terms in every part
of the united kingdom including northern
ireland and taken together
our direct cash payments will help one
third of all uk households with the cost
of living support worth nine billion
pounds so madam deputy speaker
we are meeting our responsibility to
provide the most help to those on the
lowest incomes
i believe that is fair and i'm confident
the house will agree
but there are many other families who do
not require
state support in normal times
they are also facing challenging times
yeah is it fair to leave them
unsupported
the answer must surely be no
while it is impossible for the
government to solve every problem we can
and will ease the burden as we help the
entire country through the worst of this
crisis
so we will provide more support with the
rising cost of energy and that support
will be universal
earlier this year we announced nine
billion pounds to help with the cost of
energy including a council tax rebate of
150 pounds for tens of millions of
households
and we plan to provide all households
with 200 pounds off their energy bills
from october
with the cost of that repaid over the
following five years
since then the outlook for energy prices
has changed
i've heard people's concerns over the
impact of these repayments on future
bills
so i've decided that those repayments
will be cancelled
so for the avoidance so for the
avoidance of doubt
this support is now unambiguously abroad
and furthermore and furthermore
we have decided that the 200 pounds of
support for household energy bills
will be doubled to 400 pounds for
everyone
we are on the side of hard-working
families with 6 billion pounds of
financial support
so madam deputy speaker to summarize our
strategy is to combat and reduce
inflation over time through independent
monetary policy fiscal responsibility
and supply-side activism we are raising
emergency funds to help millions of the
most vulnerable families who are
struggling right now
and all households will benefit from
universal support with energy bills of
400 pounds with not a penny to repay
in total
the measures i've announced today
provide support worth 15 billion pounds
combined with the plans we've already
announced that means we are supporting
families with the cost of living with 37
billion pounds or one and a half percent
of gdp
that's higher or similar than countries
like france germany japan and italy and
i'm proud to say
that around three quarters of that total
support will go to vulnerable households
as a result of the measures we've
announced today and the action we've
already taken this year the vast
majority of households will receive
550 pounds
pensioners will receive 850 pounds
and almost all of the 8 million most
vulnerable households in the country
will in total receive support of 1
200 pounds
let me put this into context
the house will have noted the news from
ofgem earlier this week
they currently expect the energy price
cap to rise in october
to 2800 pounds
that implies an average increase in
people's bills this year
of just under
1 200 pounds the same amount our
policies will provide for the most
vulnerable people this year
i know
there are other pressures
i'm not trying to claim we have solved
the entire problem for everyone
no government could
but i hope
that when people hear
the significant steps we are taking
the millions we are helping
they will feel some of the burden eased
some
of the pressures
lifted and they will know
this government is standing by them
a madam deputy speaker in conclusion
supporting people with a cost of living
is only one part of our plan for a
stronger economy a plan that is creating
more jobs
cutting taxes on working people reducing
our borrowing and debt driving
businesses to invest and innovate more
unleashing a skills revolution seizing
the benefits of brexit and leveling up
growth in all parts of the united
kingdom the british people can trust
this government because we have a plan
for a stronger economy and i commend it
to this house
shadow chancellor rachel reid
my damn deputy speaker after today's
announcement let there be no doubt about
who is winning the battle of ideas in
britain
party
today it feels like the chancellor has
finally realized the problems that the
country are facing
we first called for a windfall tax on
oil and gas producers nearly five months
ago
to help struggling families and
pensioners
today he has announced that policy but
he can't dare say the words is a policy
that dare not speak its name with this
chancellor
and it was labor that first highlighted
the unfairness of this government's buy
now pay later compulsory loan scheme
it shouldn't have taken a rocket
scientist to work out that this wouldn't
cut it and we pointed it out at the time
but that is just the mark of this
clarner chancellor announce now ditch
later
here he is once again the treasury's
one-man rebuttal unit the chancellor
himself
for months
it has been clear that more was
necessary to help people bring their
bills down
so what took this government so long
every day that they have refused to act
53 million pounds more added to
britain's household bills during this
cost of living crisis
this government's dither and delay has
cost our country dearly
on this side of the house we welcome the
fact that the government is finally
acting on our calls to introduce a
winful tax absolutely our call and it's
good to see the smpu turning to day two
and saying that they also are in favor
of a winful tax on oil and gas profits
well done to the snp
now madam deputy speaker
it was a painful journey to get the
government to this point
first conservative ministers said
the oil gas producers are struggling
that was the education secretary i think
but then the bp chief executive said
that the energy crisis was a cash
machine for his business
so they moved to the second defense
ministers claimed that a windfall tax
would put off vital investment
but the inner industry said that winfor
tax wouldn't even change their plans
so then they said that a windfall tax
would be unconservative
so unconservative madam deputy speaker
that margaret thatcher george osborne
and now this government are doing
exactly that
and finally the chancellor himself said
that it would be silly
silly really to offer help now given
that he didn't know the full scale of
the challenge
what nonsense it shouldn't take half a
million pounds of publicly funded focus
groups for the chancellor to realize
that helping families and pensioners is
exactly the right thing to do
now every day
for five months
the prime minister
sent conservative mps out to attack the
windfall tax
and yet defend an increase in taxes on
working people
he's made them vote against it not once
not twice but three times
and for months he sent his mps to defend
the litany of rule breaking in number 10
downing street set out in the sugree
report yesterday
now there is a lesson here for
conservative mps
you can't believe a word that this prime
minister says
and as long as he is in office he's
going to continue making falls out of
each and every one of you
if they keep him there madam deputy
speaker that is the choice that they are
making
now the problem madame deputy speaker
is that you can't fake fairness
you either believe in it
or you don't yeah
labor called for a windfall tax because
it is the right thing to do yeah
the conservatives are doing it because
they needed a new headline
and we see that too
from all the other things that the
chancellor didn't address today
the non-doms keeping their tax
privileges
while they increase taxes on working
people
young working people paying more
but those who earn money buying and
selling stocks and shares
not paying a penny more
contracts handed out to conservative
friends and donors while british
businesses miss out
global tech giants making billions in
profits
while smaller businesses and the energy
intensive industry struggle with higher
bills and higher taxes from the
conservative party
and 11.8 billion pounds lost in fraud
because of a total lack of respect for
taxpayers money
that's why we should have had an
emergency budget today
despite the hike in national insurance
to cut business rates for high street
and small businesses to provide help for
energy intensive firms and ensure that
every pound of taxpayers money is spent
wisely absolutely
madame deputy speaker we will look
closely at the detail of today's
announcements
of course
most of them seem to have been written
by us
but so far
but so far
we have seen nothing to suggest
that this conservative government has
the ideas or the energy to tackle the
challenges that we face as a country
a labor government would have addressed
the underlying weaknesses in our economy
so we can stop this spiral of inflation
lift wages and provide greater security
for families and for our country
the truth truth is that they are running
our economy and people's living
standards into the ground
we are forecast to have the slowest
growth and the highest inflation in the
g7
this government has weakened the
foundations of our economy leaving us
exposed to shocks as we lurch from
crisis to crisis
and still they refuse to come forward
with a real plan to fix our broken
system and provide the security we need
to face the future with confidence
that means boosting our energy security
too
we need to do much more to reduce
reliance on imported oil and gas
that is why labour's energy security
plan includes a program of home
insulation to reduce bills not just for
one year but for years to come
and to get us all the way to net zero
it's why we've urged the government to
double onshore wind capacity and to end
the delay on nuclear power
why did this tory government get rid of
our gas storage
order
it's important that we also hear the
shadow chancellor
rachel reeves madame deputy speaker
while we're at it why did this tory
government get rid of our gas storage
which would have left us better
protected from wild fluctuations in
prices
when will this government provide the
strong leadership that this country
needs
now there are a number of questions for
the chancellor about his announcement
today
how many people are still waiting for
the support that they were promised in
march a third of the chancellor's own
constituents are still waiting for their
council tax discount
is it the case
that households are still being asked to
pay the supplier of last resort costs
for those energy supplies who have gone
bust as a result of a decade of failed
energy market regulation
can the chancellor tell the house how is
this package being funded outside of the
proceeds of a windfall tax
and if you have more than one home
do you get multiple discounts on your
energy bills
now i know that the chancellor has
adopted two of our ideas today but can i
ask why he has not adopted a third
a cut in v80 on energy bills
it was once touted as the big brexit
bonus but he's ditched that too
madame deputy speaker this is a
discredited
chaotic and rudderless conservative
government
whose policies rarely last more than a
few months
we pushed for a windfall tax
they adopted it
we said the buy now pay to lay by now
pay later scheme was wrong
and now they have ditched it
this government is out of ideas out of
touch and out of time when it comes to
the big issues facing this country the
position is now clear
we lead
they follow
[Applause]
order order we're not going any further
unless you're quiet
thank you chairman of the select
committee mel stride
i beg your pardon it would be best if i
allow the chancellor of christ to reply
to the shallow chances
i'm not trying to change the rules i'm
just trying to go a bit faster
chancellor of the exchange say thank you
thank you madam deputy speaker i i thank
the honourable lady opposite for her
contribution
albeit her response
was based on a fundamental
misunderstanding of why now is the right
time to act
since february and march three
significant things have changed the
situation in ukraine has altered
considerably from first uh from first
and visage inflation is now tackling
considerably higher than previously
expected and finally and most
importantly
we now have concrete information on the
autumn and winter energy price cap
and with this information we were better
able to both design and scale our
policies
it is why with time and thought our
energy profits levy has a very generous
investment allowance built into it
not something the blunt instrument that
the party opposite proposes
[Applause]
and that is why madam deputy speaker
because we were patient
we have been able to scale
our support for the problem
which means our proposals are in fact
more generous than those offered by the
party opposite
because they rushed it they got their
sums wrong
but madam deputy speaker we all make
mistakes and being able to change course
being able to change course is not a
weakness it is a strength
i i won't criticize the party opposite
for getting it wrong just along as they
can acknowledge that with this package
we have got it right
just briefly madam deputy speaker to
address some of the specific points
the honourable lady i think talked about
energy security and somewhat bizarrely
reflected on the lack of investment in
nuclear capacity
well madame deputy speaker this is the
government that is correcting the
mistakes of the past
she asked about energy efficiency this
is the government that is investing six
billion pounds to improve energy
efficiency she asked about business
rates this is the government that is
delivering a 50 discount in business
rates for our high streets next year and
of course she talked about growth wall
medium deputy speaker one of the best
ways to drive growth is to drive up
business investment
something the party opposite will never
understand
she also asked about vat madam deputy
speaker and this goes to the heart of
the issue
vat is worth on average about 140 pounds
of support
our policy universally to all households
in this country is worth
400 pounds that is the reason not to do
v80 what we are doing is far more
generous
but man and deputy speaker the final
point i will make because i know we're
pressed for time is about ideas
for our constituents
there are only good ideas and bad ideas
and whether you can do anything about
them and this government can because we
are always on the side of the british
people
[Music]
this government has been faced with
challenges unlike any other and if every
step it has achieved things that the
party opposite said were not possible
we averted the mass unemployment crisis
they predicted because of our
interventions of furlough we led the
country out of covid with a vaccine
program they would have left us unable
to deliver
and each time i'm at this dispatch box
opposite the honorable lady i find
myself thinking the same thing the
public can see through it they know the
difference
they know the difference between a party
playing politics and a government trying
to help
[Music]
and now we will hear
from the chairman of the select
committee mel stride thank you
thank you madam deputy speaker and can i
uh commend this announcement uh broadly
it is a very significant intervention
that my writer or friend has made
channeling billions of pounds in a
targeted series of transfer payments
into those who most need it but as my
right honourable friend will know
similar approaches were taken in the
pandemic there were many who missed out
from support who fell through the gaps i
note the additional increase in the
household fund of half a billion which
is welcome because my right honourable
friend said out to the house how he
arrived at that figure and why he feels
that will be adequate for the demand and
could i also ask him about the issue of
inflation that he raised these transfer
payments will stimulate the economy
uh granted they will come with some tax
increases as well but could he
share the house his assessment of the
inflationary impact of the announcement
that he has just made and finally will
he appear before the treasury select
committee immediately after recess so
that we can look at these matters in
greater detail yeah
madam deputy speaker i thank uh the my
vulnerable friend for his questions i i
thank him also for his thoughtful advice
on how best the government should
respond to the current situation that's
why we put the household support fund in
place with extra support because very
specifically the one group of those on
means-tested benefits that we cannot
deliver money to automatically are those
who receive only housing benefit because
that's administered by local authorities
which is the main group that needs that
specific specific help but of course
there may well be others which is why
the fund is there and in terms of the
inflationary impact i do believe it it
will be manageable he's right to
highlight it which is why it's important
that support we provide is both targeted
where it can make the most difference
that it's temporary and that it is
timely and gets help where required and
that is the right approach being
fiscally responsible is going to help us
combat inflation in the long run
snp spokesman
kirsty blackman thank you very much
madam mr speaker
it's quite amusing to hear the
chancellor talk about this being timely
i mean it is timely it just happens to
have happened the week of the su-grey
report it just happens that that report
came out yesterday and the chancellor
has suddenly realized today that people
are really struggling that he's suddenly
realized that he needs to announce
something about it now the chancellor
stood up in the um spring statement that
he made and when he announced the energy
alone and said look at these amazing
things that i am announcing and
genuinely seemed to believe at that time
that that was the best that this
government could do
now he has changed his mind he has
listened to the calls of the opposition
he has listened to the calls of people
up and down these islands who are
struggling who are struggling in many
cases more than they have ever struggled
before
i don't understand madam deputy speaker
why he has announced only
a 15 billion pound package
he has got
he has got
28 billion pounds of fiscal headroom in
public sector net debt he has got 32
billion pounds of fiscal headroom in
balancing the current budget those are
the obr's figures from march
yet
he is refusing to spend that money now
in the timely targeted way that it is
needed
now for people he has stood up and he is
announced and it was i am very glad that
he has announced money um for the
poorest households i'm glad that it's
been targeted in that way
it's not enough madam deputy speaker
what he has announced
fails to operate benefits it fails to
account for the fact that the energy
price cap that's coming in in october
will still be in place next year it
fails to ensure that benefits are
keeping pla keeping pace with inflation
and i have to laugh about the comments
he made on inflation brexit has
increased food prices by six percent
brexit has done that people who can are
who are
struggling to make the most basic costs
whose
majority of their costs are being spent
on
energy and on food
have been hit incredibly hard by brexit
the the poorest 10 of households are
seeing a massive inflationary increase
in comparison to the richest 10 percent
of households because of the percentage
of their budget that is spent on
energy and on food
madam deputy speaker he needs to
actually uplift benefits as well as
making the payment the other thing that
he chose to do today which was pretty
cheeky was to include the 150 pound
council tax payment in all of the
figures that he was reading out the
rebate that only went to people in bands
a to d that certainly did not go to all
pensioners and that certainly cannot be
included in the money that is going to
all pensioners cannot be included in the
money that is going to all universal
credit claimants it cannot be included
in the money that is going to all
disabled people it cannot be included in
the cost of this support package because
it is absolutely not universal and on
that point the payment that we made in
scotland went to a higher percentage of
households than the payment that was
made
in england
madden deputy speaker this does not go
far enough we are seeing an energy price
increase of over a thousand pounds for
all households because of the increase
in the energy price cap and yet he's
only providing 300 pounds extra for
pensioners that doesn't even touch the
thousand pounds increase that there is
he is only including these things the
uplift should have been a nine percent
uplift for inflation it should have also
included a further 25 percent uplift to
a universal credit and a further 20
sorry about 25 pounds uplift to
universal credit and a further 25 pounds
uplift two legacy benefits lastly madame
did speaker he has failed in the uplift
to disabled people who are facing the
very highest cost because of their um
because of their increase in the energy
cost and because of the increase in
diets for example
i'm glad that he's put in place the
windfall tax i'm very disappointed that
it only covers oil and gas companies it
should have gone much wider we've been
calling for this since 2020
called for this we have been calling
this we have labour party failed to move
uh failed to support our amendment on
this last week so they're a bit cheeky
as well in suggesting that we have not
moved from this madam deputy speaker i
would like the chancellor to go further
to make a difference and to actually
care about the poorest people in our
society
[Applause]
well
madam deputy speaker i i know i know for
some people it will never be enough uh
but that's why the smp's plans would
leave scotland with i think a 20 budget
deficit and bankrupt the country uh
that's not something that we will ever
do for the people of scotland or the
united kingdom
her point on food prices i thought
surprising and slightly puzzling given
i've just returned from a meeting of
international finance ministers from
around the world where where everyone
was talking about increasing food prices
uh and as far as i know they didn't all
leave the european union but uh i
believe that to her she talked about
benefits upgrading maybe she didn't
understand exactly what we're announcing
what we are doing for those on
means-tested benefits is more generous
than operating up rating on average
would be worth just over 500 pounds
whereas the one-off payment is worth
650 pounds and then lastly she talked
about timing well madden that's really
because she mentioned many things that
have happened this week the other thing
that happened this week is we heard from
ofgem yes and we got more certainty on
what the price cap will be in autumn and
that is a single most important factor
in trying to size the support that we're
providing to people because it is energy
costs that are the biggest driver of the
inflation that we're seeing now
john redford
when the chancellor approved 150 billion
of extra cash to be printed in november
2020
and gave a full guarantee against losses
on the bonds did he then think there
could be any inflationary and public
spending risk from this i fully support
giving back the huge windfall taxis he
is already collecting on energy the vat
on fuel the the ripoff at the pumps and
the much enhanced uh profits tax coming
from nausea oil and gas that should be
given back because people need some
relief but on inflation what did he
think when he printed the money
well uh madam deputy speaker i'm
grateful to my friend for his question
he and i've talked about inflation uh
for quite a while and he'll know that i
have long actually been concerned about
the potential of rising inflation and
interest rates something he and i
discussed very early in my time and
having this job which is why from the
beginning i've been careful to protect
our public finances against the cost of
driving inflation and interest rates and
i'm glad that we took those decisions
because now we're because of that we're
in a position to act and support
people clive bets
thank you monday speaker that's a very
specific question about the household
support fund the chancellor says that
anyone i think he's saying this wherever
people live if they're in the same
circumstances they'll get the same help
from this fund in other words local
authorities will have no control over
how much money has been spent from the
fund we therefore give a guarantee that
councils will get pound for pounds from
the government every pound they have to
spend to the people who need it
no madame deputy speaker that's not how
the household support fund works it's
always been at the request of colleagues
in this house and indeed councils for it
to be discretionary uh what we generally
tend to do is provide guidance on the
types of people that we expect to have
support but leave the ultimate decision
to those in local authorities in this
instance for example as i've said the
particular priority ought to be those
who receive only housing benefit the
fund is more than size to deal not just
with those but with others as well but
ultimately we leave the discretion to
local authorities with guidance provided
by my colleagues from the work and
pension secretary and the deluxe
secretary
david davis uh okay may i give the
chancellor i'm reserved welcome for the
help for the ordinary citizens i think
now cumulatively it's north of 35
billion all told
but maya raised two concerns number one
he
uh he talked about uh the risk of
excessive fiscal stimulus how does he
reconcile that with the fact the latest
figures show we're taking more money out
of the economy than we ever have in
history
secondly on the windfall tax it will
raise a small amount of money
stability of tax and low tax both
encourage investment and growth yeah
is there not a risk that the exchequer
will lose more in growth than it would
gain in the winter time yeah
i uh i thank my writingable friend for
his uh for his question um with with
regard to uh the figures on on borrowing
and stimulus we actually are still
running a relatively significant budget
deficit this year forecast to be four
percent uh back in spring and so i
wouldn't regard that as particularly
tight uh policy on the fiscal side and
we will further as i said add support
today and with garage tax i do believe
it's important to continue to support
investment i believe the way that we've
designed the energy profits levy with a
doubling of the investment relief in it
will mean that the companies still have
a very strong incentive to invest in the
north sea
hillary
thank you very much indeed madam deputy
speaker people on pre-payment meters
many of whom are on the lowest incomes
are still paying more for their energy
than people who pay by
direct debit and they are increasingly
likely to self-disconnect
to turn off the light and the warmth
when is the government going to act to
end this price discrimination
against some of the least well-off
members of our society
well madam deputy speaker i know my
friend energy secretary is engaged with
all the companies on how best to support
people through this uh with regards to
the support we've announced today about
seven percent of households are on
non-smart prepayment meters and we want
to make sure that we get their support
to them and that has been taken into
account and will be delivered through
vouchers and the remaining
smart the remaining prepayment meters
are smart and and the credit can be put
straight on those meters so they benefit
laura trott thank you ben let's see
speaker can i write on a friend confirm
that under labour's plans my most
vulnerable consistent constituents in
swan lee and western elsewhere will
receive 600 pounds but under our plans
they'll receive 1 200.
my uh my honourable friend is absolutely
right the combination of all the support
we've announced means that someone on
almost everybody on means-tested
benefits should be in receipt of 1200
pounds of direct support from this
government and actually says double i
think the support offered by the party
opposite
christine jardi thank you very much
madam deputy speaker and the word which
occurs to me today is finally
finally after months of families in this
country proud families in this country
who've never needed help before crying
out for help from this chancellor
for pensioners who were sitting in cold
houses in the winter because they
couldn't afford to heat them
for all those people for those families
unable to put food on the table this has
come as too little
too late
as liberal democrats we were calling on
the chancellor
to bring in a windfall tax on the excess
profits of energy companies in october
when it could have made a difference in
the winter instead of which the
chancellor was hiking up taxis
and adding to the national insurance
burden of those already hardest hit so
today what i'd like to say to him is
will he listen the next time when from
this side of the house he gets an idea a
suggestion that would help the people of
this country rather than hike up their
taxis
well madame deputy speaker 70 of those
in work will pay less uh tax this year
than they did last year because of the
changes we've made and i said now is the
time to act because we have more
certainty over what the price cap in the
autumn will be we're two thirds of the
way through the observation window
offshore have given us a sense and that
means we can scale the support
appropriately
kevin holland
thank you mr speaker um can i warmly
welcome er mauricio my friend's
statement um i did think the shadow
chancellor made a very fair point
actually which was
how we're going to fund this 15 billion
pounds
but isn't it also fair to ask on the
basis that windfall taxes only raise it
would raise about three billion pounds
in labor by labor's calculations
how will they fund all the spending
plans they've announced today and in
previous occasions and the tax
reductions she's announced today and her
previous tax reductions she's announced
well my honorable friend makes an
excellent point i think at last count
we've had i think a hundred billion
pounds of spending commitments uh or tax
deductions from the labour party less
than a tenth of that has been funded in
spite of the shadow chancellor saying
that she's committed to fiscal
responsibility because it's the same old
story madam deputy speaker with labour
they ultimately always run out of other
people's money
not sure
thank you
speaker and i congratulate the uh the
chancellor for pinching some of our
ideas and i'd i'd really encourage him
to look at the 17.5 of vit as well one
of my constituents sent me a copy of
bills january 2021 electricity 10 730
170 january 2022 48 694.56
353.745
increase how is the chancellor's
statement from today and his
intervention going to help my businesses
in my constituency because it seems to
have left them out
well
madam madam deputy speaker with regard
to businesses we have the energy
intensive industry support scheme uh
which my friend the business secretary
is consulting on improving extending and
improving the generosity of that helps
our most energy-intensive industries in
the country
david gibbert
very much madam deputy speaker i've as
the chancellor knows i have spoken in
this house and to himself privately
against
labour's proposals for a windfall tax
which
i was waiting for the heckle
which in my opinion as i believe is
shared by uh the chancellor were
entirely blunt and are too blunt and
instrument and frankly punitive for the
sake of being punitive i welcome the
chancellor's support for the most for
for those most affected by the rising
costs and our welcome is more targeted
and specific
approach uh to excess profits in the oil
and gas industry and uh the relief on
investment which is already extensive as
my rentable friend knows can i ask this
two questions can he provide assurance
that the
the uh
that that charge will be applied to
excess profits and that those will be
distinguished between the profits or the
increase in profits that would be
expected in the natural cycle since the
downturn of the last
12 years and will he also commit to
continue
the constructive dialogue with the
industry that has already been evident
from this government in the interests of
energy security and energy transition to
net zero yeah
well i i thank my honourable friend and
he he's an excellent champion for the
industry and he's right to be so because
it's an important industry for the
success of our future economy madam
deputy speaker employs hundreds of
thousands of people it invests an
enormous amount and we want to see that
industry succeed and i know with uh his
support and this governments we will
make sure that that happens
gavin newlands
well rishi sunaka announcing their a
temporary targeted energy profits levy
when is that not a windfall tax
we can discuss that
throughout the rest of the day here on
sky welcome to sky news at one after
months of pressure from these opposition
parties the chancellor has announced a
winful tax on energy companies which he
says will raise five billion pounds over
the next year to help households
struggling with the cost of living
crisis will rishi sooner unveiled a
number of new measures which he says
will help people across the country deal
with soaring costs but labour has
responded by calling him a buy now ditch
later chancellor let's have a look at
some of the key announcements
well in total 15.3 billion pounds will
be handed out 650 pounds to 8 million
low-income households on benefits
the 200 pound energy bill rebate will no
longer need to be repaid and will be
doubled to 400 pounds
pensioners will receive a one-off 300
pound payment in the winter paid
alongside the winter fuel allowance
and a one-off cost of living payment of
150 pounds will be paid to those on
disability benefits on top of the other
we should not be ideological about this
we should be pragmatic
it is possible to both tax extraordinary
profits fairly and
incentivize investment
and so like previous governments
including conservative ones we will
introduce a temporary targeted energy
profits levy but
we have built into the new levy
but
we have built into the new levy
but we have built into the new levy
a new investment allowance similar to
the super deduction
that means
that means companies will have a new and
significant incentive to reinvest their
profits
today it feels like the chancellor has
finally realized the problems that the
country are facing
we first called for a windfall tax on
oil and gas producers nearly five months
ago
to help struggling families and
pensioners
today he has announced that policy but
he can't dare say the words is a policy
that dare not speak its name with this
chancellor
and it was labor that first highlighted
the unfairness of this government's buy
now paid later compulsory loan scheme
it shouldn't have taken a rocket
scientist to work out that this wouldn't
cut it and we pointed it out at the time
but that is just the mark of this
clarner chancellor announce now ditch
later
well our economics and data editor ed
conway is here in the studio ed so
financially how how great a difference
will this make to the worst off well it
depends on kind of you know which types
of households you're talking about
because a lot of this was quite targeted
on particular groups so you've got you
know for eight million people on
means-tested benefits uh there will be
this one-off uh payment of 650 pounds
it's a lot of money that is a lot of
money and it's gonna cost quite a lot of
money as well five billion pounds uh but
that is significant uh particularly for
those on lower uh incomes and means
tested benefits for pensioners you've
got a kind of one-off 300 pounds for
those on disability benefits one off 150
pounds
you know the these things are pretty big
amounts of money so that's not
insignificant at all and you know some
people might want to be dismissive but
you know this is quite this is really
quite a lot of money obviously in the
face of what people are going through a
cost of living uh disaster though like
which you haven't seen for many years it
is still not necessarily going to mean
that you're kind of
up compared with the previous year but
that's quite a lot but looking more
broadly at kind of you know average
households it's it's kind of a slightly
different story let me show you actually
because we you know earlier on we were
looking at some of these uh charts
basically showing the the kind of
history of what's happened uh with
spending on energy and this is kind of
what this comes down to and a lot of
what british united was talking about
here uh was trying to keep this line
down
the amount that we spent on energy going
back all the way to 1957 is has always
been within that kind of that border
that blue area you can see and recently
it's gone up uh to
uh well that's that's the expectations
that's where it is at the moment i
should say it's kind of highest level
since the 1980s that dotted line shows
you uh where it's expected to go later
on this year the 2800 pound price cap
and obviously look at that dotted line
that is the highest in terms of the
share of people's incomes that they're
spending or their total spending that's
going on energy that we've ever seen
before so the question is how does the
chancellor get that down and last time
in the spring statement and of course
those plans with the energy rebate um he
got the line down to there
and what's different this time around so
extra money rather than it being 200
pounds for most households it's 400
pounds rather than being a rebate it's
permanent and that brings this down look
at the the kind of red line and look
also at this dotted line here the share
of our spending that we spend on energy
i'm going to show you where we are
potentially as of these plans
you can see it does go down and it's now
kind of within that
that box so we're no longer in
unprecedented territory it would only be
what i say only in inverted commas uh
the highest since the uh the late 1980s
that's a slightly rough and ready
calculation but that's kind of the best
i've been able to work this out this
would bring down total spending on
energy quite significantly and worth
saying as i you know said a moment ago
it's different for different types of
households this is the average household
to the extent that there is such a thing
but looking across you know if you are
on means-tested benefits if you're a
pensioner uh then and receiving winter
fuel allowance so not all pensioners
then you are potentially going to see a
significant fall compared with this but
bear in mind as well for a lot of people
on lower incomes this the amount they
pay on their energy and the higher this
is the more you're paying on your energy
it's a share of your total spending best
way of looking at it over time that is
much higher for different income groups
i mean there are all sorts of other
things in there actually it was getting
quite a lot of info to to absorb the
other thing obviously was what happens
with uh the windfall tax i think we can
call it a windfall tax i think we've
decided that you know this is basically
a winful tax uh and so far you know
previous uh profits from shell and bp
that was last time around just to give
you background about why you know more
money potentially will be coming off
this so the chance that we'll be taking
a lot more money uh out of the profits
of those energy giants
but here's the thing you're getting
about five billion pounds he said from
that because this is not a budget we
don't have full kind of figures from the
chancellor which is a bit frustrating
you're getting about five billion pounds
uh from that this is a 15 billion pound
package so you've still got extra money
that needs to come from somewhere where
is it going to come we're going to have
to see and there's other bits in there
besides that you know uh the things like
the triple lock coming back in things
like benefits being upgraded that could
be incredibly expensive in the coming
years uh so there's actually quite a lot
in this to to discuss and you know i
know you know over the course of the
next few hours we'll bring you more
analysis on what's coming through as we
get the data uh from the treasury um but
but also just all these all these
u-turns jane i mean
you know you can call them u-turns you
can call them kind of convenient uh or
pragmatic changes but you know not long
ago rishi sunak was against the triple
lock it was all about the double lord
not long ago uh he was against windfall
taxes now it's about windfall taxes not
long ago uh it was about energy
repayments now it's grants uh and
finally that fact on how the energy can
i just show you one more thing the
energy outlook has changed he said in
this statement so everything has changed
the reason we're doing this the reason
we're doing all these u-turns is because
everything changed well you know
actually
back in the march spring statement the
office of budget responsibility said you
know we're talking about 2 800 pound
bills already so no actually the outlook
for all of our bills is basically the
same as it was last time around it just
seems like something else has changed
and that's you know there's a lot going
on politically and clearly also there's
there's an acknowledgement that maybe
what they did before just wasn't enough
well let's talk about what has happened
politically and perhaps why it's
happening today our deputy political
editor sam coats is here and sam uh
alluded to it and rishi sunik said there
in in the commons to change courses a
sign of strength not of weakness this is
a change of government course isn't it
absolutely extraordinary in the way that
they've pivoted it was just a matter of
weeks ago that the treasury was
insistent that there'd be no more help
really until the autumn and that's the
point where energy prices go up again
they delivered the help in the spring
statement which was just three months
ago which was a statement wherever she
said that
wrapped himself in the language of the
need for fiscal responsibility we saw
none of that today 15 billion pounds
spent but i don't think that includes uh
the long-term increase in benefit uh
payments that he talked about
when it comes to
upgrading uh some of the key benefits uh
from next year so this is incredibly
costly but as ed was just alluding to
you do wonder uh quite what the
definition of conservatism is under
boris johnson at the moment uh given
they didn't want to do anything they've
now had to they've abandoned their
opposition to the windfall tax even if
they try and call it something different
um they've abandoned their attempt to
claw back uh money on energy bills uh
he's doing something one of the big
points in the spring statement which was
rishi sunax big moment just three months
ago was which was to say look we can't
do anything else that would be
inflationary the cost of uh servicing
our debt is extraordinary it's over 80
billion pounds inflation is the key now
he's doing a lot of stuff that as one of
his own back benches pointed out could
well be inflationary which you see that
today just said well that's the price
you've got to pay uh it'll it'll be
worth it and this is a fiscally
responsible conservative party paying
for it through borrowing not spelling
out where the vast majority of this
spending is going to come from 15
billion pounds if you exclude the
benefit stuff uh being um
being spent to date five billion pounds
uh i believe from the windfall tax so
where's the other 10 billion coming from
is it the money that would have gone in
the future to perhaps paying for that
income tax cut
and you mentioned tax cuts this is just
the start we're being told that if there
are going to be tax cuts there almost
certainly are they'll come in the autumn
budget so a few more months to wait but
you'll have a conservative party uh
banking this large amount of spending
and then asking what's next in terms of
uh
tax cuts uh in just a few more months
this is not a conservative party of the
sort i think that george osborne were
particularly recognised
and what about the timing of today's
announcement of course funnily enough we
had the partygate inquiry released
yesterday uh we've had two mps saying
that they're not backing the prime
minister since then is it curious that
that register suddenly decided today to
make this announcement oh of course it
was jane this announcement today was not
absolutely nailed on on tuesday it's now
thursday and they just spent 15 billion
quid so of course the political context
is all uh you saw the sugray report
yesterday we have now had three
conservative mps uh come out uh since
that to say that boris johnson should go
yesterday julian sturdy today john
barron uh and david uh simmons
interestingly all making different
arguments why he should go john barron
uh suggesting that he just thinks that
boris johnson is responsible in a way
that sue gray uh didn't uh uh uh sort of
uh a
responsibility to sue grey didn't
specifically assign him to so uh john
barron going further than the sugree
report david simmons just saying look
boris johnson isn't particularly popular
anymore uh with the electorate uh so
you've got those uh mps coming out i
think 15 billion pounds will help calm
nerves a bit because tory mps who as of
today after this statement will head off
back to their constituencies for recess
they'll have something to say to their
constituents
other than just having to defend
allegations around partygate but my
sense it took twofold first of all i
think talking to lots of mps this
morning that people are still digesting
the impact of the sugray report
politically in a funny way we've just
had the last few minutes danny street's
official spokesman apologize personally
for lying to journalists for months this
is not normal behavior this is not the
kind of politics that almost any uh tory
mp is is proud of but then they'll also
have to work out
um whether this just ends up looking
like a gigantic check to try and make
some of these political problems go away
i'm sure the opposition will make that
case the government will say this is
help needed urgently needed now
but will boris johnson just throw money
at the country every time he's in
trouble maybe there's a case for it
maybe it's popular maybe that's the
right thing to do but i think is going
to be the conversation uh in the uh
weeks and months to come okay we're
going to move on for this but i know ed
you could you want to come in just to
echo two points that sam has made yeah
first of all where is the where is this
10 billion pounds coming from actually
at the moment the treasury is not
especially clear on this but it's a lot
of money and secondly a lot of this will
be really inflationary the chancellor
started off his statement by saying we
need to fight inflation and then the
second half of his statement is doing
things that are basically going to bake
in further inflation for the coming
years so there's some weirdness going on
not to think about ed and sam thank you
both very much great analysis well if
you have any questions about the cost of
living crisis we're going to be having
an hour long q a with experts on the
issue at seven o'clock tonight
scan the qr code on your screen now or
email news at sky.com to get your
questions answered
well let's move on now to the us and
there's been criticism of the police
response to the shooting at a school in
texas in which 19 children and two
teachers were killed it's emerged that
the gunman may have been in this school
for up to an hour before he was shot
dead the father of one of the dead
children has spoken of the tragedy as
well as a nine-year-old boy who escaped
the attack ashnahui nag reports
what chance sauron heard on tuesday
afternoon will likely haunt him forever
a salvador ramos stormed into rob
elementary school he and his friends hid
and waited to be rescued everybody was
scared
we were all panicking because we didn't
know what was really happening what we
saw were thousands of police and barbara
troll coming into the cafeteria
and we were all hiding behind a stage in
the cafeteria when it happened
all